pendant tout l'été et par beau temps ce
qui n'a pas été le cas aujourd'hui
nombreux sont les jeunes qui sont venus
passer quelques heures sur les bords du
lac kir au centre de loisirs ouvert
depuis maintenant cinq années un centre
dont l'originalité est d'avoir été créée
à l'initiative du corps urbain de la
police de dijon ce que nous confirme le
capitaine trouille et oui c'est exact il
fonctionne sous l'égide de la police
urbaine de dijon plus exactement c'est
le club sportif de la police urbaine qui
en est l'animateur et cela en relation
étroite avec le service départemental de
jeunesse et sports il a été créé il ya
combien de temps et bien été créé il ya
cinq ans sous l'impulsion du commissaire
central de dijon qui estimait devoir
utile procurer aux jeunes et loisirs
alors que ces mêmes jeunes des zus des
quartiers populeux de dijon sont
désoeuvrés pendant l'été les parents
travaillent n'ont pas le temps de
s'occuper des enfants ou ne peuvent leur
offrir des vacances le commissaire
central a donc estimé loire utile créer
ce sens de loisy là jusqu'à présent vous
avez accueilli combien de jeunes cet été
nous avons accueilli au total près de
200 jeunes au centre de loisirs coffret
t-il aux jeunes de la région dijonnaise
il offre aux jeunes la région dijonnaise
sous
on est nuls de notre lac les activités
de yachting c'est à dire la voile
canoë-kayak jeu de boules jeu de volley
ball ping pong cours d'éducation
physique démonstration de judo etc
notant que quatre animateurs ont été en
permanence à la disposition des jeunes
cet été deux venant du corps urbain au
lycée régions de tours et gagner les
deux autres venant des services de la
jeunesse et des sports
mais à leurs côtés d'autres sont venus
volontairement les 1 du club sportif de
la police d'autres des mouvements de
jeunesse
alors c'est donc un rôle d'animation
qu'a choisi de faire sur les bords de
lacs de dijon la police urbaine mais je
crois qu'au delà de ce rôle d'animation
et aussi bien sûr la mission de
surveillance qui incombe à toutes les
forces de police et un autre aspect si
vous voulez de la présence sur les bords
du lac kir
les policiers du conte urbain le poste
de secours est ici a pour mission la
surveillance de la plage principale tous
les baigneurs qui la fréquente pendant
l'été est également la surveillance des
voiliers les canoës kayaks qui évoluent
sur le lac